on a entendu pendant la crise que la
culture n'était pas essentielle et c'est
vrai que quand on est professionnel de
la culture c'est quelque chose de très
violents c'est dire en fait à la
personne ton profil n'est pas essentiel
tue mais pas essentiel
pourquoi nous on serait donc un danger
pour le peuple que d'autres formes
professionnels
[Musique]
pour moi la danse est pas à 15 mètres
les uns des autres pour moi la danse et
pas par écran interposé et je pense
qu'on ne peut pas priver une population
de quelque chose qui est aussi essentiel
parce qu'au contraire ça permet de
partir dans sa tête de partir dans ces
émotions également parce que période qui
est aussi anxiogène il faut réussir a
extériorisé ses émotions et donc du coup
c'est très douloureux de devoir se dire
voilà vous restez chez vous pouvez voir
personne et vous pouvez même pas exercer
en fait ce qui vous fait vivre il ya une
forme de colère
[Musique]
moi j'étais j'ai été formé en france
ensuite je suis parti à new york chez
alvin et les élus je suis resté sept ans
travailler là bas en tant que danseur et
puis après en développant la compagnie
azad d'initiateur pour lesquelles je
travaille aujourd'hui la compagnie est
revenu en france en 2018 et la ville de
blois nous a fait venir dans le loir et
cher sur blois pour développer l'art
chorégraphique et donc c'était un
premier choc culturel moi de revenir en
france et de voir en fait la politique
autour de cette forme artistique et la
crise sanitaire m'a finalement quelque
part permis de poser des mouvements
poser une réflexion sur ce choc culturel
et nous avons malgré tout développé deux
pièces tirées et fuck the boxes pendant
ce confinement autour d'un synopsis
commun donc une pièce que j'ai
développée d'une façon dramatique
quelque part la douleur qui est causé
par le fait de ne pas rentrer dans les
cases et ce même sujets qui étaient
traités aussi d'une façon comique donc
là on fait the boxes on emmerde les
caisses justement de dire que ben on est
pas tous pareils on peut être parce tous
dans les cases mais c'est ça qui fait la
beauté de l'art etc c'est ça qui devrait
être mis en avant plutôt qu'une forme
artistique
unilatérale
malgré tout ça malgré la crise malgré le
jeu politique malgré la vision qu'on
peut voir de la danse ce qui me pousse
vraiment aller vers l'avant c'est
vraiment de dire il faut il faut il faut
habiter son corps il faut voir des corps
en mouvement il faut soit mettre en
mouvement une façon ou d'une autre et
des personnes qui ne dansent pas ou qui
ne savent pas être en mouvement de voir
des jeux en mouvement ça leur permet
aussi d'extérioriser et il ya ce ce lien
invisible dans le spectacle vivant là
dans la danse en l'occurrence qui est
100 mots qui est vraiment une forme
artistique qui est que par le corps et
qui permet aussi par des personnes qui
ne sont pas en mouvement d'avoir un
mouvement intérieur